bonsoir merci d'être avec nous le chef
de la diplomatie européenne qui assure
donc kiev de son soutien indéfectible
en tout cas celui de bruxelles quelle
est la portée de cette déclaration pour
le moment ce sont des mots depuis
longtemps depuis le début du conflit
bruxelles soutient kiev même si il y à
une médiation française et allemande qui
oblige la france l'allemagne a éteint un
peu moins favorable à kiev et essayer de
d'être impartial ces derniers temps ce
n'est plus réellement le cas
actuellement on est dans une phase très
très particulière c'est en quelque sorte
une prophétie auto réalisatrice
vous savez lorsque on pense qu'un que
l'adversaire va faire un mouvement ont
fait soi-même un mouvement et la dette
certains suspects soit ce mouvement
comme une menace et avance lui même est
finalement alors qu'il n'y avait aucune
raison que les choses s'enveniment et
bien le sens venir naturellement et on
est au début de ce mouvement est ce
qu'il va s'arrêter
vraisemblablement parce que personne n'a
intérêt à aller plus loin dans le
conflit ça veut dire quoi concrètement
on sait que les relations entre la
russie et l'europe sont déjà très
tendu vous venez de le dire personne n'a
intérêt à aller plus loin dans le
conflit mais ça risque d'empirer est la
lumière des derniers événements
il ya toujours une possibilité de
dérapage lorsque je dis que personne n'a
intérêt à aller plus loin dans le
conflit c'est dans ce conflit là c'est à
dire le conflit du donbass avec des
dizaines des centaines de morts c'est de
ça qu'il s'agit
je crois que actuellement la situation
est très claire
d'un côté il y a les républiques
autoproclamées qui sont sur leur sur le
territoire qu'elle revendique elle ne
revendique pas autre chose
elle ne revendique pas d'aller plus loin
en revanche l'ukraine depuis 2014 veut
récupérer ses territoires
eux ils ont tout intérêt à aller plus
loin à grignoter des territoires
actuellement par la négociation rien
n'est possible parce que l'un des
accords l'un des principes de minsk qui
était l'un des points essentiels pour
les républiques autoproclamées c'était
l'autonomie inscrite dans la
constitution et ce à kiev depuis
maintenant six ans s'ils refusent les
accords de minsk 2 ont été signés en
février 2015 fait ça fait maintenant
plus de six ans que ils ne sont pas
appliqués à cause de ça effectivement un
moss quoique je ne craignent de ne pas
respecter ces accords de minsk
clairement ils sont en danger
ils ont ils sont un danger ces accords
de minsk pour une conception de
l'ukraine qui et l'ukraine état unitaire
à l'image de la france c'est à dire en
france pendant un siècle entier le
jacobinisme pas imposer aux moyens
parfois de massacres comme en vendée
mais plus tard par des politiques très
rigoureuse
que les particularismes régionaux
disparaissent et on a créé par la
violence par la contrainte un état
unitaire
aujourd'hui c'est formidable nous sommes
tous français que l'on soit alsacien
breton ou provençal nous sommes tous
français en ukraine ce n'est pas le cas
depuis trente ans on essaye de créer un
état unitaire alors que les
particularismes sont très très virulent
très très marqué dans dans la population
ukrainienne
il y à des citoyens ukrainiens qui avait
jadis la nationalité russe ou grecs ou
peu importe
et qui aujourd'hui ont perdu leur
nationalité ils ne sont plus considérés
que comme ukrainien c'est un peu comme
si ils avaient été dépouillés de leur
identité et ses identités là aussi bien
dans le dos basque dans d'autres régions
comme la transe que la transcarpathie
les les gens aimeraient bien pouvoir
s'auto gérer d'une certaine manière il
ne demande pas à sortir d'ukraine il
demande simplement que les la
constitution ukrainienne leur donne le
droit de de parler leur langue de
s'entendre dans leur langue et d'avoir
leurs particularismes régionaux
c'est tout ce qu'ils demandent ce que
vous venez nous décrit très bien pierre
laurin c'est un aspect de la question
qui n'est pas de considérer qu ils n
aient pas vues par justement l'europe
non l'europe ne voit pas cela parce que
elle considère que l état ukrainien doit
être unitaire et
il n'y a pas de raison qu'il y ait des
particularismes d autonomie il n'y a pas
de raisons pour les européens de voir
leur propre exemple si vous avez
l'allemagne est un état fédéral
mais avec une langue unique donc c'est
un peu particulier mais la grande
bretagne c'est un état c'était avant de
sceller toujours mais elle ne fait plus
partie de l'union européenne mais c'est
un état également avec dédé d autonomie
très forte pour les différentes régions
qui se considèrent comme des états et
nous mêmes nous les considérons comme
des états puisque nous organisons ddd
match de rugby avec des
des participants qui pour la plupart
sont des des britanniques mais on
considère que le pays de galles et anita
etc
en espagne les autonomies ont une large
liberté même si le roman même si
certaines demandes plus comme la
catalogne et pourquoi refuserait ton
incertaine région ukrainienne ce que
l'on considère comme normale dans
d'autres pays que je viens de citer
alors kiev dit que la russie veut tester
joe biden
voilà et en russie on estime plutôt que
l'ukraine seraient prêtes à attaquer se
sentant soutenus par washington qui dit
vrai je crois que pendant tout le tout
le mandat les cinq ans ou petro
porochenko était président il
n'attendait que le feu vert de
washington pour lancer une attaque parce
qu'ils suivent croyez que les forces de
l'otan
le soutiendrai évidemment lorsque donald
trump est arrivé au pouvoir à washington
ccc espoir n'était plus aussi
l'actualité ce qu'il convient également
de voir c'est que l'otan organise en
ukraine des déformations pour l'armée
ukrainienne qu'il y à des manoeuvres qui
sont prévus dans un proche avenir que
l'otan en elle-même organise
régulièrement des manoeuvres tout le
long de la frontière russe en mer noire
des bateaux de l'otan mènent également
des manoeuvres régulièrement et là on
voudrait interdire à la russie de faire
des mouvements de troupe à l'intérieur
de son territoire
je rappelle que les forces américaines
qui sont en europe dans le cadre de
l'otan sont à 6000 km de leur base
et on voudrait interdire aux forces
russes d'organiser des manoeuvres ou des
déplacements de troupes à l'intérieur de
leurs propres frontières
ça c'est un peu un peu curieux c'est à
dire c'est une conception 2d du droit
international qui est très particulier
donc nous nous avons le droit en tant
qu'occidentaux de faire ce que nous
voulons nous voulons mais en revanche la
russie elle n'a pas le droit de faire ce
qu'elle veut à l'intérieur de ses
propres frontières
merci pierre laurin d'avoir été avec
nous avoir apporté votre analyse